Oh my god, the first challenge, oh sorry, I was late.
The first challenge was getting this game to fucking work on
PC.
I was just like, I spent an hour just trying to fucking
figure out how to get this game to run.
And then, thank god you guys, I should have asked you guys
for help in the beginning.
Because I was just like, how?
How do I, how do I make this work?
Oh, so I've never seen this intro.
So I guess we watched this intro.
Look, there's a pretty bird.
That's me.
I'm that bird.
Oh.
Oh, oh, oh.
Oh, my God.
Who are all these characters?
The only guy I know is, like, king.
Because he's, like, half Jaguar or some shit.
Bum.
Oh, my God.
This song is hype.
The sound guy here.
Yeah, I had to do admin mode.
And then compatibility.
That's how we had to do this.
It was the first challenge The first challenge in this game
All right, sound god good you're here I don't know any of
these characters I'm literally going in blind as a
I'm going in fucking blind I have overall 10 minutes of
Tekken gameplay over in the series in general fighting game
wise maybe like like a couple of hours But that was because
I was like that was a little jockey playing the marvel slash
tree fighter arcade machines Whoa, there he is there's king
Where are these other guys?
My god, he has a gun wait is he OP?
Yes
That's all I know.
He has a gun.
Can I do anything with that?
Bro, could they give us super chat?
Thank you.
The lore about Tekken is about a very dysfunctional family
and daddy issues.
Being played as a panda and a space samurai.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Wait, who's OP?
Who's meta?
Is anybody meta right now?
Tekken 8.
Alright, the issue is that how many times am I going to
crash?
can crash a lot uh in this game or am i just gonna be
picking eddie
because everyone's like go pick eddie and then what was it
spam something
surely the people at my you can okay all right wait i'm
using controller though wait do i use controller uh do i
just use controller pick the funny any my beloved what's
three you guys just can't say three i don't know what three
is like which controller i'm using an xbox controller uh do
i use controller keyboard tech it is three okay what's three
okay i assume that what is three there's no three here it
starts at 12
It starts at 12.
No, it starts at 5.
There's not even a 3 anywhere It literally starts at 4.
It starts at 4 and not 3
It starts at 4 and not 3 also So yes, the reason why Mercy
thank you super chat.
Thank you.
Meta is too hard spam a on eddie or spam y on victor oh a
okay that's great i love the a button i love the a button
okay so the reason why i'm playing techin at the moment is
because i got invited to the was it the sayjam uh sayjam
slam uh tournament sayjam say i'm sorry because that's the
organizing day sayjam sayjam is this a jam or sayjam
say jam okay say jam slam two uh tournament and i have zero
experience i was like but i have zero experience and they're
like perfect i'm just as surprised as you guys that i'm in
the tournament as well i literally told him he's like oh my
god stream fighting i was like but i have zero experience
and he's like perfect that's what we need i was like Okay.
Lil does he know?
I also have zero experience overall.
The perfect target.
D-Dragon, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Correct me if I'm wrong, but 1 equals X, 2 equals Y, A
equals 3, and 4 equals B.
Also, King has a couple of grads that do a ton of damage and
newbies cannot break.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
So, yes, I'm very thankful to get invited as well.
For those who also don't know, I also got invited to the
Nokia Apex Tournament.
I knew about this for a while now.
I was just waiting for it to be announced.
They even sent me like a welcome package.
Like they said, everybody who's participating.
A welcome package.
I haven't received it yet.
But I won't spoil who the team is.
Who's in my team.
We have a team going in already.
It's a hide and seek tournament too, by the way.
Yeah, I just retweeted it.
I just quote retweeted it.
But we got invited to a Nokia hide and seek Apex Tournament.
That's happening at the end of the month.
You guys are going to find out who's on my team later on.
Whenever it's revealed, I have no idea when it's going to be
revealed.
I didn't.
I just found out they tweeted it out today.
And then they were like, oh, quote retweet it when you can,
guys.
So I was like, okay, I'll do my part.
I'm going to do my part.
But it's okay.
There's a lot of pro players in there.
But like, it's hide and seek.
So it's like, what are you going to do?
Hide better?
Like, if anything, I'll just follow where the pros are
hiding and then grief them if I have to.
Yeah, this is the one that this guy's toast and wig is
hosting.
Yeah.
No, but thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
French Guilf Victor.
Go pew pew.
Teleport pew.
Thank you.
And as thank you.
The fighting game bell curve means by having zero
experience, you might beat many with limited experience.
Thank you.
The super chat.
So yeah, I have no idea what to expect in this.
in a tournament um because i have no experience at all other
than button mashing so so it'll be i can i can button match
better than all those other newbies out there if they don't
know what i'm gonna do how do they counter exactly if i have
zero patterns how do they counter me
Dictable exactly I don't know what they're gonna be doing,
but I know my strat Why is that it next?
Okay, there you go cross-platform do I have one
cross-platform or should I just play with all the PC people?
cross-platform Okay, if all else fails and I actually can't
if I if all else fails and like I'm actually that too stupid
to recognize patterns and mashing my beloved will be here
for me uh barely can you barely see the image i don't even
see it at all we'll just go with equal all right is that
there we go benchmark score 1028 is that good i can't tell
in order to optimize performance all right this game has an
auto save okay cool
They have coaches?
That's true.
But am I coachable?
Please enter your player's name.
All right, sure.
Oh, wait.
Everybody's going to see this name.
So I should actually.
Wait, I can't type.
How the fuck?
Please use your keyboard.
I'm literally trying to type my name.
Wait, what?
It's not even...
My keyboard's actually...
not registering oh my god i have no name i can't i want to i
actually can't oh my god oh wait okay there you go oh there
you go i figured out real okay there we go what's my name
there we go complete.
There we go, we did it.
So real.
Yeah, look, Eddie!
Should I buy Eddie right now?
Wait.
We'll be releasing an additional player.
Do I have Eddie unlocked?
Wait, guys.
Give me a sec.
I need to know.
Do I have to buy Eddie?
He's my Trump card.
It's time to buy Eddie.
Do I have him?
Eddie.
How do I buy Eddie?
How do I buy him?
Not buy him.
Wait, do I have him?
I can't tell because I got taken aid for three free.
Guys, this is why I got invited.
This is a this is a joke.
Okay, I need to preface that this is a joke, but this is why
I joined.
I got taken
huge shout out they actually gave me a free copy of Tekken 8
so I didn't have to buy it a huge huge shout out to them for
actually this is a joke by the way because I was gonna buy
Tekken 8 regardless but free is free you know free free is
free nice all right okay introduced okay how do I
optimization where's like options okay options all right
sound settings how's the sound by the way i mean i feel like
voice has to be always up uh yay free game woo i love it
okay uh button map okay we don't need to know any of that
all right let's see offline mode uh quick match maybe i'll
do one quick match and just see how how fucked I get.
No, let's just go straight in.
Bring music.
Okay, enjoy battling with new style.
Use Tekken 8s to easily master your favorite characters,
unique moves and combos.
Even if you're new to using, enjoy fighting with it to
memorize.
Oh, cool.
Press X to unleash a heat engageer, ideal for offensive
play.
If heat is already activated, your heat here quick match is
Quick match matches what?
Oh my god.
Press Y for a combo starter.
Press Y to repeatedly...
How many instructions are there?
Press A, you can activate Power Crush.
A counterattack used when getting attacked.
Press A, when you think an opponent is...
Oh, this is a counter!
Okay.
Droves can be performed with B, B, B.
RB is a button that unleashes the heat system's special
moves.
Perform a heat smash by pressing RB during heat.
You'll go into rage mode when your health is low.
This boosts your attack power and you'll be able to use your
rage with RT.
Rage, what the fuck am I?
Turn on special style?
Should I turn it on?
Do I do I turn on special?
I mean, like No.
Okay.
Maybe I shouldn't be in quick match.
Fight against a CPU opponent to calculate your starting
rank.
This will be dedicated based on your performance in battle.
And all that matches you will be matched against.
All right.
Can I pause CPU battles?
Choose.
I won't be on the left side.
Okay.
Where's Eddie?
No, I don't have Eddie Did my game crash?
How do I select?
Sweet!
Oh,
I'm loading.
Oh, okay, okay.
It crashed?
I can't tell.
This game has baited me for so long.
It crashed and it had just I can't tell if I've crashed or
not.
Oh, special style equals aim assistance.
Shouldn't I turn on special style?
Zeta, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
I can't tell.
Is it crashed?
That's not in this way.
Am I, am I, am I still in?
No, actually a deep bump.
No!
I can't tell!
This game has baited me for so long!
I can't tell if it's crashed or not!
Yeah, guys, I actually can't tell.
I crashed.
Never mind, I can tell.
No.
Never mind this music's here forever.
Oh, oh, oh, oh Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, we're just gonna
listen to that forever I guess okay All right, well, we got
to like watch it a little bit.
I was fun Guys, we got we got into the menu that was pretty
fun guys The game stopped me from going into Quick Match
Even the game knew it was a bad idea was like don't keep
please play the tutorial i was like but what if though but
when if i go straight in you learn the hard way you know
it's like when those mama birds push their babies off a
cliff to be like if you don't fly you die that type of deal
that's me if i don't fly i die look the best thing about
having overall 10 minutes of Tekken knowledge is that
there's zero expectations of me so and I'm okay with that
I'm okay with zero expectations unlucky thank you for the
super chat thank you thank you who is that Doki's first
actual battle in Tekken is with Tekken itself okay we just
need to get past like the we just need to get past the
fucking rain menu like all right here we go you turn down
the graphics i feel like i should that sounds very important
actually maybe that's why i crashed i i didn't turn down
anything i just went straight in All right, we got to turn
down the music and then also I already brought it up overall
Guys, I didn't have time to set up my new PC.
I've been so busy
Great start What do you think of the game so far?
I mean with my limited not limited experience with my only
experience being the main menu It seems pretty cool, you
know It's only been in the game menu but like other than
that seems pretty fine all right um bgm okay there you go
that should be good right where's the graphic settings am i
in ultra mode oh okay okay that that makes a little more
sense all right all right here we go Yes.
That's a yes, I am.
All right, what else do I need?
Do I put on medium?
I think medium sounds like the best area to be in.
So, like, that seems right.
That seems a lot better.
All right.
I'll bring it up a little bit more.
Okay, I'll bring up the sound volume a little more.
Let me know if it's better sound, guy.
I brought up the sound a little bit more.
Right, rendering scale, uh, view sync off.
Okay, V-Sync off.
Where's V-Sync?
Okay, there you go.
Anything else that I should do?
Medium is premium.
All right, remove shadows.
Do I not need shadows?
Okay, shadow.
All right, there you go.
That should be fine now, right?
We should be good.
Now we don't have to see the pure sweat from this guy.
I'm dripping out.
Oh, I need a bite.
Guys, give me a sec.
I need a bite, Eddie.
If all else fails, I have Eddie.
All right, tech and shop.
How do I buy Eddie?
I'm going to the shop now.
Guys, this is important.
Eddie!
Okay, I just need to buy the DLC, right?
I already have Tekken 8.
Wait, how do I...
Eddie, there he is.
How much is he?
It's $10?
I mean, that's fine.
If all else fails, I have Eddie.
I'll pull up the Eddie if I start losing.
Pay it a win.
Let's fucking go.
I got Eddie, you guys.
Guys, guys, I did it.
I bought Eddie All right.
That's all I need.
All right.
Let's see.
Yay!
Eddie, you know what?
I think I can do a quick match now.
Wait.
All right.
Fight me goods.
One, two, one.
It's Eddie.
All right.
It can't be that bad, right?
there's no way there's no way it's gonna be that bad right
like no way it can't be that bad if I play Eddie it should
be fine right all I do I'll just I'll just play Eddie it's
true what it's like to be but you guys I need you guys to
not play Eddie though only i play eddie chat only only i
she's so dead what do you mean i'll just play eddie it can't
be that bad press what's three get a right that's that's
that is that right a how do i how do people join my lobby my
i'm real female change your character wait how do i change
my character so many things i need to know how to do
dragoons this time show no mercy to our Oshi.
I'm not like, thank you for the super chat.
There's a password?
Oh, there he is!
Mighty Ruler?
Wait.
Is that... Is that scary?
Is that...
Tric-Turkey's beautiful.
Wait, don't pick Eddie, though.
Don't pick Eddie.
I only I pick Eddie.
You're playing raw without any story?
I don't need no story.
How do I change characters?
Guys, Guys, I'm not ready.
I'll be on the left.
Oh, there you go.
Oh, my God.
This took for...
Eddie.
I brought up the volume.
Is it better?
Sound guy.
Guys, I'm Eddie.
He might have played Puff.
or how would you know purple rake might not be that bad guys
look see he has his stats are at d it can't be that bad okay
don't don't don't do anything first let me at least have one
hit chaser let me at least bring it up more after you get
destroyed because all i'm saying is if you're a real dragoon
You would let me at you spam you Is that the street fighter?
Please give me a don't don't don't come over yet.
Oh my god, what don't come over yet, please don't do wait
give me a sec Give me a don't don't come over
Bro calm down.
There's no friend I got a hit it's not
a hit Oh
my god guys what the fuck I thought you were purple that's
why you can't predict this right that's looking right you
can't predict this oh yes I got it round that's looking
right can't predict this you know what perfect anymore not
perfect that's fucking right I got around you can't perfect
this that's fucking right oh I don't know what I'm doing
because you can't predict the shit no way how do I spam
three what is three I don't know what is three what am I
doing Doing This is ping I don't know.
I don't know how how am I spamming three.
Okay, how do I block?
What did I do?
Okay, I did that Whoa, that's right.
No predictions
Literally only a wait, what did I do?
How did I do that?
how the how the fuck did I do that it's okay he didn't
perfect me that's okay that's okay he didn't perfect me I
won what the fuck is going on good question wait I try to a
wait no perfect no perfect oh shit he fucking passed me down
I won the spirit because I took two rounds off of him and
now he's Oh, that's fucking right.
That's fucking right That's fucking right.
Oh shit.
I'm trying to try to spam a It's okay It's all right Did I
really lose when I got two rounds off of him?
Did I really lose Is it truly a lie?
Where I brought got two rounds off of this guy
That's a king right I don't know guys.
I think I I think I won here spiritually I think fate actor
shake my head and then thank you the super chat.
Thank you.
Thank you Did you know what you're doing?
Absolutely not I told you I If it all fails, bring out the
Eddie.
Let's watch these guys play.
And then we'll do the tutorial.
I'm willing to watch this.
How do I watch this?
Am I watching?
There are no winners.
All I'm saying, all I'm saying is that I've managed...
Oh my god, this guy's S+.
Wait, he wasn't even playing his...
Is this hero?
Oh my god, it's Hitman!
Wait, that's so cool!
The customization is crazy.
Alright, I brought up the volume more now, sound guy.
Alright, here we go.
Oh, shit!
How do I get rid of the chat?
Chat display.
Oh, there we go.
Alright.
If you lose this victory, bad oh my god look oh my god bro
look at him okay look at that look at kaiser fucking look at
that this guy actually plays the game and look at how much
he's losing
too costly i took a round off these two oh my god never mind
wait these guys are equal these guys are like equal man
you're fp i feel like Maybe I should go low.
The frames is pretty bad.
Holy shit.
I feel like they know what they're doing.
Because they're actually blocking.
I feel like...
Oh my god.
They actually know what they're doing.
They're like figuring out each other's combos.
How do you...
they do that set up the pc but it's so much work and i have
so much other work to do
no keep but i was very clear on what i was doing oh my god i
told you guys if i button mash nobody will know what i'm
doing they can't like counter they can't counter me if they
don't know my patterns
So he said it.
All I need to know is how to block.
I feel like if I realize...
I feel like if I realize how to block and then I button
mash, things will be okay.
The more you play, the less frame drops you will get.
Oh, okay.
It's still compiling.
Okay.
But did you win the set?
I've got two rounds off of him.
That's all I'm saying.
Hold back to block.
Oh, okay.
Oh, shit.
He's getting absolutely destroyed.
Oh my god.
Guys, maybe I'm meant to be purple rank.
Maybe I'm meant to be a flame slash mighty ruler.
Hold on back to block.
Alright.
Alright guys.
Guys, have fun in this custom lobby.
I'm going to do the tutorial for real now.
Guys.
Leave session.
Sorry guys.
I'll see you later.
I apparently have to Whoa!
I got money!
I got million Gs!
Whoa!
Apparently I should actually know how to play this game.
Alright, what is the tutorial?
Is it the story?
Or is it offline?
Is it arcade quest?
Practice through an exciting For apparently I actually have
to learn.
This mode training arc begins.
Is arcade quest?
Arcade quest?
Okay, arcade quest.
Okay, I got this.
Okay, but for real, like, what do I actually play?
Do I actually go full?
Do I commit to the Eddie?
Or do I play King?
Because apparently King is also, like, good to...
Good at destroying noobs, too.
And I'm a noob as well.
So if I destroy the other noob first, then I win.
Play whoever looks cool.
But I want to play whoever is meta.
I want to play whoever I can use as a crutch.
Whichever character I can use as a fucking crutch.
That's all I want.
There's always plenty of smiles and sounds of button
clacking.
King, Eddie, okay.
All right, thank you for the gifted shit.
Thank you, thank you.
see.
There is no meta.
The meta will change on May 9th.
Well, thank God the tournament.
Wait.
Isn't it May 9th?
Oh, wait.
It's already.
It's not May 9th.
Uh.
Do not play King.
As long as I can grab.
Is that all that matters?
As long as I can grab somebody.
I might not know what I'm doing, but I can grab someone.
King is hard.
late.
Meta this, meta that.
But have you ever met a girl before?
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Where's your pal at?
They're supposed to be.
Oh my gosh.
I'll go look for them.
You guys head on without me.
Which one's me?
Okay, see you then there.
Okay, I'll be there when the turn he starts.
Oh, that's so cool.
Is this a lobby?
Call me.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Where are you at?
This place is packed.
What the fuck is Max?
Is that you, dragons?
know what you're wearing today and i'll come back for you
whoa he wants to know what we're wearing wait is this
default i think i love default face already
okay okay i like i like the face already is that face like
whatever you wear bro i want to keep this face i actually
like Actually, wait, wait, but I could be an absolute chat-
Oh, wait, no.
Does the Chad face work?
No.
Okay.
You have to say, this looks like a Chad's face.
Okay, I'm going to keep this.
I actually really like this.
Wait, I can be purple or yellow.
Wait, I can make a dragon.
I want to make a dragon.
Okay.
A dragon.
All right, here you go.
And then, let's see.
Oh, what kind of hairstyle would work?
I guess this.
And then, oh yeah, this works.
Okay, how do I change the color?
How do I change the color?
Oh, there you go.
I read.
There you go.
And this is a dragon.
It's a dragon.
What are you saying?
Now you guys have to, like, root for me.
Because if you, if I lose, you lose.
All I'm saying, if I lose, you lose, because I'm playing as
you.
Okay.
All right, let's see.
Do I want a beard?
What is that?
What is the...
Oh, there's a beauty mark.
Uh...
Okay, wait, wait.
Do I want...
Let's see.
Actually, we'll do this one.
Yeah.
And then...
Perfect.
That's you.
It's you.
It's the dragons.
Yeah.
All right.
What do we want you to wear?
Cover everything up.
No, I worked so hard for this.
Oh, I can have hats too.
No, we can't cover this.
We can't cover this.
Okay, let's see.
Uh...
Is there anything else?
Oh, wait, we should have a different...
We should wear something different, though.
Let's see.
Oh, my God.
You guys can be edgy.
Do I have money?
I do!
I have money!
Alright, I want you guys to wear something edgy.
Um... Oh, my God.
Yes!
For our king cosplay!
Alright, and then...
What do you want for your pants?
I mean, I have a million dollars.
It should be fine.
I feel ins...
Why are you insulted?
You look beautiful!
Okay.
Are you thinking about what pants to wear?
Ooh, short shorts.
Short shorts.
Oh, wait.
There's more.
Okay, wait.
Short shorts.
Alright, here we go.
This is our king cosplay.
Uh, and then shoes.
I'd actually like...
Oh, yes!
Oh, my.
my god you guys look fabulous uh and then we have a
friendship bracelet but you guys don't see it guys don't see
the friendship bracelet it's here in spirit it's here in
spirit all right nice i finished this is you guys looks like
some one cord order to be enjoying some love ginger thank
you for the super chat thank you thank you all right finish
editing save and exit i'm the dragoon.
Dragoons, you're looking at yourself.
You're beautiful.
Are you trying to say you're not beautiful?
Because I think you're beautiful.
Look at you guys.
I hope I didn't crash because I tabbed up.
I'm good.
There you go.
I didn't think it was super... There you are.
I started thinking you weren't gonna show.
Man, my heart's beating like crazy.
You feel the electricity in the air.
We've all been waiting for this game to drop for what feels
like forever in a day.
You see any free machines?
Yo, this one.
This is Tekken 8 at last.
Hold on.
Did you play any of the previous games?
Absolutely not.
Play all the tutorials.
Don't sweat it.
Don't call me the Tekken prop at my local arcade for
nothing.
ropes no problem okay are we learning the next battle did i
did i crash guys i got ready for the next battle and then i
crashed you're with a super chat thank you thank you wow
doky your homeless bread sims and cosplay looks off guys i
got ready for the next battle and then it was over
please let me at least do the tutorial please oh my god
please that's all i want i couldn't even get ready for the
next battle everybody no i
got baited i got i got baited I can only enjoy the sound of
the battle.
Zachary, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
You made a character worthy of Dr. Cresty.
Thank you, the super chat.
Thank you.
Did it save?
Did it save my dragon?
I was not ready.
Yeah, I was absolutely not ready.
Guys, did it save?
Did it save, guys?
No!
You just lost.
Guys, no!
No!
I just want to get ready for the next...
Don't you have a monster PC?
Yeah, it's sitting outside my room.
I haven't even unboxed it yet.
I just didn't have the time to set up.
That was so busy.
Antonio, thank you for this super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Your very first super chat.
Thank you.
I really appreciate it.
Antonio, hey, thanks for accurately depicting my severe...
Yes, feeling the love.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
All right, we're going to lower the quality a little bit.
Maybe it's the graphics.
Maybe.
Okay, medium.
What else do we lower?
What else can we lower, though?
Guys.
But you need the PC.
better maybe you'll get better you don't know that go window
mode would window mode actually help at this point go to 480
anti-alias okay we're gonna do it with um maybe the
anti-alias will help all right here you go this is it this
is it this time i'm ready for the battle
All right, this is it.
This is me.
We're going to turn this into a Doki and chat while she
finally sets up her new PC stream.
Grassy, daisy, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
This is it.
Please don't make me remake the dragons.
Oh, yes.
No!
No, that's not me.
Wait.
Yes?
Yes.
No!
Please save my dragons!
It didn't save!
Oh!
It did!
Oh my god!
I knew it.
You're here forever.
Airpoint Ninja, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Peace.
He's haunted.
I knew it.
You're here forever.
Now you got it.
Yes!
Tekken remembers This is your This is like You know What was
it called?
You know like when they turn like Pokemon into human design
What's the word for it?
That's your real design When you're a person
You're like artists who used to like Make like Yeah Gijinkas
Yeah that's you guys That's your Gijinka form Yeah Did it
crash?
No.
It's still okay.
It's just loading.
Your PC is actually dying.
We're so...
You're not ugly.
It's like the most accurate representation.
Trust the problem.
It's okay.
Just trust.
We didn't crash.
It's just loading.
Guys.
No, it's not.
It's not crashed.
Guys, Tekken 8 has baited me so much.
It's just bait.
If all else fails, I'll just use the PlayStation version of
Tekken.
I just asked.
No, it can't have crashed.
There's no way.
Please, at least let me...
Alright, we're gonna do a window mode.
Why does it take forever to load?
I don't understand.
Alright, guys.
We're gonna read...
Guys, we might have crashed.
Or it might have been...
We might...
I think you guys were right.
We should have done windowed mode.
You know, it's funny that...
You know what's great, guys?
We gotta play...
We gotta play, like, one match.
Alright.
No, it's not dead!
Don't say that!
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
It shouldn't change this to our PC style stream.
Look, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Look!
I'll make sure I'll have the new PC ready before the
tournament.
I swear.
I'll have the new PC ready for the tournament.
I just didn't have time 50 FPS that's almost playable thank
you for the akasupa thank you thank you for helping and then
thank you for the super chat thank you thank you I get to
play one match though I got that one match in me all right
okay guys let me play window mode maybe that's it that's it
this is what we needed guys this is what we need need it
guys we'll play all we need is to it's to play window mode
that's all we need rassy thank you for the super chat thank
you thank you okay graphic settings all right window
borderless borderless this borderless should be fine right
okay it's because i was It's because I was playing on full
screen Now I'm on borderless now.
We're okay This is it.
I swear we're not doing If I can't even fucking play the
tutorial, I'm just gonna go into a quick match I'll learn
live I'll just I'll learn the game live With actual people I
There we go.
Skip movie.
Yay!
You guys are finished editing.
Guys.
It's moving.
The 8 is moving.
Oh my god.
There I am.
I showed up.
We showed up.
I knew it.
It's all because of the borderless.
Oh nice.
It saved again.
again all right this is it get ready for the next battle i'm
ready
guys it might be stuttering but the eight is moving the
eight will move that it's moving the particles are moving a
little bit it moved it's okay all right x is left y right
punch b right click a kick a left kick okay i got this okay
arm right and then kick okay we got it oh and then this is
how i do the eddie spam right but i'm not eddie though just
practicing my eddie right now on the wrong character
okay we're fine Alright, nice.
Let's try some important mad inputs.
What the fuck?
Oh, shit.
Is that a combo?
I can do that.
Oh, look at me go.
Directional input.
Okay.
There.
I did it.
Wait, how do I do that?
How do I do that?
Did I do it?
You see how to press a button early?
How do I?
Did I not do it?
I did it!
See, it said great!
There you go.
I did it!
Wait, directional input?
Oh my god.
Did I do it?
Yeah!
Robin, thank you for the super chat.
thank you thank you oh i'm good to go now you heard that
they said i'm good to go should i be using dpad or guys am i
supposed to use the dpad or the directional or the analog
stick
that pc is heading to the like dpad oh okay because i was
using the analog stick okay now i know actually that means
losing your own health is bad yeah of course you beating me
up?
I hold you can... Oh, that's how you block!
I figured it out.
Try to block and hack.
Boom!
Oh, wait.
There we go.
I figured out how to block.
Look at me go.
Alright, now I know what you're thinking.
You stand there and block everything.
You never lose.
Yeah!
But there's an issue of low attacks and throws that can't be
blocked using.
Oh, so I have to block, uh, I have to, like, go down.
Okay.
You can use a crouching.
To do a crouching block.
Okay.
I got it.
Try to block a low attack.
Boom.
Just block everything.
If I block everything, they can never do damage.
Yeah!
That's right.
Woo!
Perfect.
I lay out the base I did it!
Alright, checking the heat system.
What's this?
Now I'm going to teach you about the heat.
A super important battle system.
You notice that you have another gauge besides the health
gauge?
That's the heat timer.
When you have a heat timer, it means you're able to activate
heat.
You start every round in this state.
How do I do that?
RB.
Okay.
Oh!
Heat activated.
You can see the timer looks different now.
Your character is stronger if heat activated.
there is a time limit so you don't stay strong forever so
you can use it once per round so timing is key oh that's
easy i'll just use in the beginning y'all swim moves are
only available when he try busting out a heat smash now that
is nice
all right
he smashes it ends in the only good thing about heat state
you can only add you can also get the added bonus of chip
damage with all your moves your opponent's oh so they can't
block my moves technically i see recommended air combo when
he activation activated what the fuck checking is all about
the air combo and then what is that it no wait Did I do it?
He activated during...
What?
Okay, wait.
And then I do it again?
Oh!
Okay, I forgot to press it the second time.
Alright.
I'm learning.
I didn't read the last half.
They got me in the first half.
Not gonna lie.
Master the balances.
Next you have to pick a character and get fighting.
Okay.
They got me in the first half.
All right, my game crashed.
But I was so ready.
I was so ready,
though.
I was so ready.
I was about to pick everything.
I don't understand.
okay i'll try dlss i got the shader error i got the shader
one
i don't understand i did everything for techin please the
game got toky in the first half not gonna lie i don't have
my pc set up before the tournament i promise i promise anton
thank you for the super chat thank you thank you bro cool
thank you for the super chat thank you thank you you're
actually learning i think you actually have a game sense and
gaming skills become good at the game okay i don't know how
much copium you're on right now thank you for the super chat
thank you thank you okay all right it's time to go even
lower than what than before all right all right All right.
It's time to go as low as we can.
How low can we?
We don't need the good graphics, guys.
We don't need to see the man's pores.
So much.
Hope you are doing well.
Thank you, the super chat, Brian.
Thank you.
All right.
Let's hope we can...
We'll put everything...
It was just...
It's time to put everything on low.
It's time.
okay all right we don't need a look at the man's pores guys
like we don't need to know what's going on with his skin all
right let's see uh what's this is this is there dls here amd
amd performance balance quality nis dls ultra performance
balance quality there we go that sounds That sounds about
right.
There we go.
We're on the quality sector.
Okay.
Here we go.
They're not quality.
Oh, wait.
We won performance.
Wait, where is it?
Where's performance?
Okay.
There we go.
Performance.
Not quality.
here we go there it is we'll be fine now guys surely all
right guys we don't need arcade anymore it's time let's do
the kitty episodes where's eddie select story mode
difficulty you know what medium let's go eddie i learned how
to block where's eddie where's e for eddie wait there's no
eddie episodes is he not important I find Eddie important.
Is there king at least?
There's no king?
How is he not important enough to have his own story?
Oh, well, spicy.
I guess we'll do the dark awakens.
There are buns.
Up until...
Would you like to go before starting the story mode?
For first time players.
Okay, sure.
What's the story anyway?
How long are these?
Tekken 4 summary?
Okay, let's just read.
what's going on in seven king is right there
who's that guy maybe i should not have started with techin
seven
Is this a spoiler?
I mean, it's Tekken 7.
We've taken your gamer rig for granted.
Gary, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Oh, this guy's dead.
Whoever this guy is.
That's it.
only we can stop Kazuya I'm Kazuya I can stop Kazuya
if that was blood
Oh my god.
He grew tattoos.
We figured it out, guys.
We figured out the story.
Alright.
I guess that was the story.
So can we play now?
Fight money.
Why do I need a purchase?
Oh, it's because of the gallery.
Oh.
Wait, someone said King's actually in there.
Where's King?
A, B, C, D, E, F.
Oh, King.
No, let's try it.
Okay, apparently King grabs are good.
King, that's me.
undisputed pro wrestling champion ran an orphanage that
rescues children from all over the world wait so why does he
have a jaguar head however due to the war between g
corporation and the mishima zibatsu the orphanage was
already well beyond capacity the troubled wrestler then
remembered the recently announced the king of iron fist
tournament and came up with a plan because it's cool
He's so cool.
Okay, it can't be a mess.
He's literally talking in grouse.
Like, unless he's super immersive.
Why not?
That's me!
He does it for the children.
Get ready for the next battle.
I'll be fighting against the law.
How do I grab?
I realized I've learned everything but grabbing, and that's
this whole thing.
Witness the might of the undisputed champion.
Guys, I realized there was one thing I didn't learn.
Oh, but did you see the block though?
Oh, shit.
Oh, fuck, okay.
All right.
It's fine.
We gotta use this heat moment before the round ends.
Oh, shit.
It's fine.
oh fuck i still don't know how to grab that grab i
a or x okay a x or a b all right i block two okay there you
go i'm grabbing i got it i'm grabbing give me grab let me
grab they don't know how to counter grab grab wait if i keep
grabbing
i did it get ready for the next battle Oh my god, this is
it.
I'll just keep grabbing.
I figured it out It's over.
It's over for all the other nooms.
I don't even know how to break a grab.
It's over.
Oh shit.
Wait a minute.
No, no, no, no, no, no.
Let me grab you.
I got the strat.
Okay, maybe not.
Guys, maybe I should stop that.
Okay.
No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no!
Yes!
No King's Laird knows how to break the grab.
It sounds accurate.
If I keep grabbing, if I keep grabbing, this is it!
It's gotta keep grabbing!
Let me grab you!
Okay.
Yes!
We figured it out.
Oh shit, I quit.
That's right.
Can't counter to grab.
No, no, no, no, no, no, no.
She's becoming king.
All right.
Winners play offense.
All right, here we go.
We figured it out.
Go, king.
Go.
How is she doing that?
Okay.
No one, no, none of the noobs know how to counter grabs
because I don't know how to counter it.
Oh, shit.
That's fucking right.
No, no, no, no, no.
No, no, no.
Wait, how are you countering me?
You're an NPC.
That's fucking right.
How do you counter this?
No.
Oh shit.
Oh, don't worry.
I still can grab you.
That's fucking right.
Oh god.
No.
He can't hit the grab.
No way.
There's nice.
Nice.
There you go.
It's okay.
I just keep grabbing.
There's no way.
There you go.
That's fucking right!
Check the PC.
The NPC is learning about my grabs!
How?
How is he learning?
Oh shit!
No!
Fuck, okay!
He's countering my grabs!
How?
I don't know how I'm countering!
Oh god, oh no, oh no, he's juggling me.
This might be it.
The NPC is learning.
He cancelled it.
He cancelled.
Oh god.
Oh god, no, no, no.
Nice.
This is a strat!
Get ready for the next battle.
I just know what XA and what was the other grab.
Try up xy.
Up xy.
The AI is self-aware.
Guys.
Oh, why did I try xy?
No.
Oh, no.
He's learning.
He knows my math.
He knows.
Oh, my God.
How does he know?
How?
Okay, nice.
There we go.
Boom!
That's fucking right.
I'll just keep grabbing.
Oh, shit.
Okay, never mind.
I'm so sorry.
Nice.
I'm doing it.
There we go.
Grab tab.
Okay.
Oh, my God.
It would be crazy if he knew.
Actually, if actually people...
It would be crazy.
crazy if the newbies actually learn how to counter the grab
i will be so sad
i'll be so sad because this is actually my whole strat oh
god oh god please no no no no yes yes the grab all right
here we go he has multiple
There's coaching.
It's okay.
They're not gonna register.
There's no way.
Try running and then grab.
Oh my god, I should try that.
Okay, never mind.
Oh!
No, I tried to fucking go.
Okay, nice.
I got the grab here.
Nice.
Oh, no, no, no, no, no, no, no.
Block, block.
There you go.
Block.
No, come on.
Yes.
No!
Holy shit.
He's insane!
They have Steve learn!
I can't believe it.
Steve learn.
Did I grab him?
Nice.
Okay.
Oh, God.
I grabbed him again.
That's fucking right.
Get grabbed.
Come on.
I'll just keep grabbing.
Come on!
Come on, kid!
just keep grabbing yes keep grabbing oh shit oh shit no just
grab him back oh god oh no Steve no oh god oh god just no I
got cated but I got outgrabbed Okay Oh Oh god Okay That's
fine That's fine It's my turn That's fucking right It's my
turn That's fucking right Oh shit No Steve had mercy Steve
had mercy Let me grab you Come on Come on Let me grab you
Come on I just need one grab I literally just Oh my god,
he's so good!
Steve is so good!
Holy shit!
I'm getting out-counted!
Oh my god!
He perfected me!
Oh, Steve!
My skill wall!
There's no way there's gonna be a newbie.
There's no way that's gonna be a newbie that's just as good
as Steve.
I refuse.
There's no way I refuse to believe that Okay, it's okay We
might not be able to grab him as well as Oh my god, what the
fuck?
Okay, no, please stop doing that Please, please don't make
me use this
Okay I blocked my turn That's right That's fucking right.
Yes!
Oh, God.
Okay.
Grabbing the...
No!
No, it's over for you.
That's fucking right.
Oh, God.
He blocked it.
Yeah, you did block shit.
That's fucking right.
I figured it out.
I'm learning.
I blocked and then grabbed.
Here we go.
Just you wait and see.
Wait, I think I do it.
There's no way There's no way the other noobs can learn how
to counter a block Grab
There's no way How would they learn
They will There's no way They'll never figure out They'll
never figure out be a grab main that's the spirit come at me
again after all you've got i need to learn the chain grab oh
my god i'll be unstoppable exactly i don't need to be good i
just need to suck less than everyone else if only they had
coaches to teach them then they could learn they'll never
know they'll never expect me to be the i'll practice king
off stream and i'll play every other i'll play all the other
Tekken characters, so they'll never know who my main is.
And I'll, like, hard grind King, and all I do is just grab.
How would they know?
Surely they won't research my first stream.
Surely they wouldn't.
Yeah, okay, we need to get the chain grab going, and a lot
of people can't counter it.
Before this gets done.
I'll play every other character, but King.
next couple of streams and then a hard grind and then
they'll be like oh my god surely dokey bird is like an eddy
main so all we have to do is learn how to count all you have
to do newbies is to learn how to counter like the okay but
what if the other people play king wait how am i gonna like
oh my god i got the beast and like oh my god i got player
customization they'll never know
how would they know i'm a king mane oh wait hey that's my
avatar wait how do i player customization which one is use
outfit oh here you go my title how would they know i'm a
king mane
but you and your players health gauge change the design your
player information instead of the magic mirror how would
they know Let's see.
Where is the beast?
Wait, I got the title plate, right?
Where is the... Which one was it?
Is it this one?
Which one was the one I unlocked?
Wait, that's so cute.
Was it Legend plate?
Tekken Emperor plate?
Which one was the one that I unlocked, guys?
Title?
Yeah, I know, but which one is the color?
That's... Which one is it called, guys?
I don't remember.
I unlocked it, but I don't remember.
Far down below the locked ones.
Oh!
Wait, no.
These are paid.
At the bodies.
Liars?
What is the one that unlocked?
Oh, there it is.
How would they know?
Guys, how would they know I'm a king, man?
There's no way.
There's no fucking way they could find out.
2D is all I need.
Wait, that's great.
Where's the one I unlocked for this?
Is it the play information panel?
You missed the beast.
Where is the beast?
Today's the day.
Where's the beast?
I can't find it.
I found tea drink here.
Where the fuck is the beast?
beast.
Down?
It's further down?
Yeah, but these are all locked.
Where's the unlocked?
Oh, there it is.
That beast.
There we go.
They'll never know.
Guys, they'll never know I'm a king mane.
How could they?
I don't They found out I'm a beat.
I'm the king main.
They're fucking stream snipers They'll never know Save and
exit there we go I'm sure they're eight minute king guys.
There's no way.
I refuse to believe they'll find out If they find out
they're hackers Be around how would they know exactly?
How the fuck with you know what?
I'm ready I'm I'm fucking ready
I'm so ready this is it there okay we'll do no max number of
participants wait actually fuck it we'll do Well, there you
go.
There's no way that you won't know.
Guys, how would they know?
How could they possibly know the mind games?
That should really must not be a king main.
I'm not.
Who said I was?
I told you.
My server, my session says not a king main.
So how would they know?
Just like...
No, just don't play...
Okay, but how do I...
Wait, how do I counter another king player?
Just... It's so easy!
I'll grab them before they grab me.
Chat.
I'll grab the king player before they grab me, and then
it'll be GG's.
It'll be GG's from there.
It's hard to get a read on...
Me?
Quick, guys!
Come in before!
Guys!
Start!
Hurry up!
Join me!
join join join click enter the hotline servers are going
down in two minutes hurry join click yes
while you're so smart yeah grab them first before they grab
me exactly i'm on the left side where's king oh nice there
you go they'll never know i bet they don't know which one i
picked Hurry!
Hurry up!
We're maintenance!
We gotta start!
It's okay.
I learned this.
Guys, I learned how to play.
They couldn't pass.
I bet they didn't expect it.
I bet...
Guys, I bet they didn't expect this.
There's no way.
Okay.
Oh, yeah, that's like...
Oh, shit!
He got her by grab!
And now I'm lagging!
Oh, how did you know?
Oh, my God.
How did she know?
How?
Oh, my God.
Guys, how the fuck does she know?
I'm so...
I don't...
I don't understand.
How?
What does she know?
That's fucking right.
Yeah, countered this bitch.
You can't count as shit.
Oh, God.
It's fine.
I got one in.
It's okay.
I got it.
Oh, my God.
She's countering my everything.
No way.
You can counter grabs?
Why?
That's fucking right.
Countered this bitch.
It's okay.
I got my one.
I got my one grab.
That's all that matters.
That's fucking right.
Get chaotic.
I learned.
I adapted.
Oh, you want to grab too.
Yeah?
Oh, my God.
She grabbed me.
How is that possible?
Oh, she countered my grab.
Oh, yeah.
I bet your whole idea is to counter all these grabs.
Oh, my God.
Okay.
That's fucking right.
But you did.
She's countering my grabs.
Yeah, right.
Counter this.
Bitch.
That's a key.
That's a key, right?
You fucking didn't counter all of these, did you?
You didn't counter this.
I got one off you.
I had zero Tekken experience, but I took a round.
I took a round off her.
She knows how to tech it.
What's embarrassing is that she, I took a round off her.
That's the embarrassing run
That's right I got She couldn't counter that Like queen shit
No one can deflect this No No Alright we'll do one We'll do
a story mode Rip online Just remember The zero The zero zero
techin experience dokeybird took a round off you by just
spamming grab
it's more embarrassing for you than it is for me to lose
because it's expected but it was not expected for me to take
a round off you i'm impressed all right nice can i keep
playing king I got the round one I have nothing exactly I
have nothing to lose I have the moral victory my ego can
only go higher because I start at rock bottom not a king
main I don't play king in this mode what how can I exist
Without King!
I'm playing gym?
I'm sorry for all the gyms out there.
What kind of fuck are you guys?
Fighting character name is Jim!
I'm fucking playing the office guy?
I'm in gym mode.
I'm stuck with emo gym.
I'm playing the office?
Oh, Jim!
I thought you guys said Jim.
I was like, sorry, Jim Tekken.
Sorry, Jim.
It's Jim Map.
I thought you guys, sorry, I can't read.
I thought you guys said Jim.
Okay, that's pretty badass.
I was like, why is his name Jim?
But his actually name is Jim.
No, his name is Jim.
Yeah.
Mishima.
Is that his name?
I wish I was king.
I miss king, guys.
I already missed him.
Oh, that's a dad.
Oh, shit.
Can he grab?
All right, guys.
Oh, my gosh.
Okay.
Oh, my God.
I jumped this other thing, though.
Can you grab?
Wait, you can grab.
Wait, how good is your grab, though?
Okay, it's okay.
I'm just gonna keep grabbing.
Wait, he dodged!
Oh my god, it's not the same.
It's not the same, guys.
It's...
It's not the same.
His grab is not the same.
It's not the same as King, though.
King was cooler.
Wait, what?
Dodge.
Oh, okay.
Okay.
Go look down.
Yeah, that's fucking right.
That's fucking right.
And then I'll do this again.
Yeah!
Oh, shit.
Okay, this time.
I blocked it, I think.
Yeah, I did.
I did.
I blocked it.
Oh, shit.
No, no, no, no, no, no, no.
He shot me in the fucking gut.
Oh, guys.
Nice.
Alright.
Okay, and then, please, grab him, Jin!
Grab him!
Yes!
Grab him again!
We're king!
Guys, I can't grab him.
By the way, Toki, all you need to know about this family is
that they keep throwing each other off really high cliffs.
Glassa, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
The worst...
King.
This one goes out to King.
Oh shit, nice!
Good old-fashioned family drama.
I love it when my frames go to 18.
Whoa, I have wings now.
Holy shit.
How many forms do I have?
All right, watch this.
I can block this.
Oh.
Guys.
Guys, I can block one, right?
There's no way.
Yes.
Okay, I got it.
That was, I count that as a block.
I count that as a block, guys.
Okay, here you go.
Okay, did I block that?
That, no, I did it.
Holy shit!
Guys, it's because I gave him one.
Holy shit, my laser eyes.
That's insane.
Oh, nope.
How am I doing worse?
Oh, I think that was a block.
I think I actually did that.
Oh, God.
Okay.
No, no, no, no, no, no.
Nice.
That's fine.
Okay.
No, no, no, no, no, no.
Yes!
Blocked!
That's fucking right!
Oh, no.
That's not okay.
Oh, I tried to fly!
Why did I try to fly?
No!
Oh, wait.
Nice.
The game protected me.
I blocked.
That's right, guys.
Story mode.
Jeez.
Guys, what are you talking about?
I'm lude.
I'm lude, guys.
I don't know what you're talking about.
Is this devil mode?
I guess because he has, like, black wings?
Am I going to kill my dad?
This is not Clift.
Oh, shit.
Love watching this in, like, 30 FPS.
Guys, I perfected it, because I had full HP when I...
I had full HP when I ended.
What the fuck?
Is he also a devil?
Whoa.
What do I do?
Oh my god, my lasers.
Okay, I'm gonna block.
fight okay oh shit how is that supposed to know you what
what the fuck what is oh it's okay i grabbed and he counted
my grab guys this is bad this guy's the cpu is learning
that's right i blocked though but i'll block high now no oh
my god why is he so It's a CPU guys.
It's because I'm not king.
I can't do this without king.
He was my crutch
He was a fucking crutch
What what the fuck?
Oh my gosh Okay, oh my god, he's so good I'm trying!
I need to stop grabbing because it's all I know!
It's actually all I know!
I'm so used to grabbing!
It's just pure instinct!
It's actually pure instinct, my grabs!
I've been doing it so much!
Okay, nice.
Can't block this.
Oh!
Wait, he did though!
Oh God.
Oh, it's okay.
Oh God, it's not okay.
Oh God.
It's like blocking all the time.
Oh!
Why is he so good?
How's the AI learning so much from me?
It's actually sane.
I learned so much.
He regents?
This is bullshit.
There you go.
I got grabbed him.
Oh my god.
I need to stop grabbing.
It's all I know.
It's actually all I know.
Don't keep their unblockable as this game.
Anyway, good luck in learning the game.
Thank you for the super chat for the first super chat.
Hi, Akuya.
Thank you.
Oh my god, please.
Oh my god.
holy shit i'm getting absolutely destroyed
guys this is bad i'm actually getting absolutely destroyed
there okay i know how to kick though that's fucking right oh
no that's not good it's okay i still know how to grab this
is my legacy
over hit him low then high okay I got it hit him low then
high oh my god but he hit back I can't believe it a fighting
game and he hits back that's insane that's right I'll grab
you that's fucking right oh shit nice come on yes come on oh
yes him low wait he's still alive i did it i learned
what's going on what the is going on i broke the crab how
i mean i knew how of course I know how.
Random.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Whoa.
It's okay.
We can rebuild it.
Hey, why are we in New York?
Should we be in Japan?
Why not?
Oh, and he chose New York?
That's fucked up.
Admiral, a few city blocks have been lost.
Just another day in New York.
...
Revan, ...
I mean, I'm speaking in like...
Wow!
Hey, they're like universalists.
Do they all have life?
It's French.
Do they all have, like, earpieces that translate each
language or speaking?
Doki, when she realized other players have coaches that can
teach them how to counter grabs.
Surprise, Pikachu face.
Thank you for the Super Chat.
Doki, thank you, thank you.
They would never.
Yes, but they can't counter my grabs.
There's no way.
At best, if they get better, they won't be matchup with me.
Because as long as I don't improve,
as long as I don't improve, I'll still be matched up with
all the people in my rank.
Yeah,
but like, the thing is, they have to, we're matched up to,
like, our level.
So I just like Thank you for the super chat Thank you, thank
you No, I don't show my strats on stream That's the key I
figured it out Like I said, I'll play everybody but king So
they won't They won't Think about countering me On king
They'll like try to Figure out how to counter me On every
other Character But king
Oh, apparently all tech characters Under your sand each
other Wait, that's crazy that's that's insane it's amazing
i wish that was real i can just let understand everybody
else's languages.
Yay!
Oh, wait.
There's me.
He wishes he was king.
What's that?
Is that me too?
Oh, yeah.
It's devil me.
Simple and clean.
Sora wake up Sora wake up
Oh is that my mom
I think he has mommy and daddy issues Clearly Developed by
Bandai
Whoa What is that?
He's better off as an orphan Not gonna lie with all those
issues I feel like he'd be way more well-adjusted if he was
an orphan.
Yeah, he has mommy issues.
The issue is she's dead.
Oh my god.
What's this?
Mashima.
Wait, he's rich.
Who's Mashima, right?
I'm a...
Oh my god, he's so rich.
How does he have so many issues?
It's because he's this rich that he has so many issues.
His dad is rich, him not so much, but then he gets the money
passed down to him.
It's called inheritance.
If rich, why evil?
Okay.
That counters each other.
is rich is even no no rich person is innocent that's how
they get rich in the first place it's been one week since
kazuya mishima head of g corporation shot down the key
military satellites while the militaries of the world are
unable to function the qualifiers for g corporation's
tournament have begun The whole world is watching this
tournament that gives power to the victorious country and
levies penalties on the loser
Who's this
Am I fighting him
Who's Lars
all right here we go i got this oh oh i blocked did you guys
see that oh my god okay wow shit did i block oh shit bro
sorry actually got the tutorial accident there you go nice I
stepped on him
I blocked guys, I figured it out Oh shit, sorry I got too
excited I got so excited that I blocked I forgot about
everything else
Okay, oh no, oh no No, no Rob block!
Oh, God.
Oh, my God.
No.
He counters me.
No!
He led my patterns!
Oh, shit.
Oh, no.
That's not good.
That's not good at all.
This is all I know how to do.
Oh, shit.
No.
I lose.
I got one round off him.
How do I lose?
He gets two rounds and I get one?
This is absolutely bullshit.
Can't believe it.
This is so messed up.
I can't believe it.
It's fine.
No, no, no, no, it's fine.
Oh, he's not seeing it!
Ah, I blocked so many!
Okay, and then he fucks me up.
There you go.
Oh, yeah, I see that.
Whoa!
Get comboed, dude!
Okay, they won't expect this.
The AI can't expect that.
I told you, the AI cannot expect that.
Guys, I got a combo going on!
Oh, shit!
No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no,
no, no, no.
Grab him!
Oh, God.
Come on.
Nice.
No, no, no, no, no, no, no.
Yes, grab!
Boop!
Yay, I'm making progress.
How can you predict chaos?
Exactly.
Yeah, they can't detect my combos if I don't know the
combos.
Exactly.
What's this?
Oh no, I'm having PTSD.
No, I'm not a Jin character.
I'm king.
And if you are one of the participants trying to scope up
the competition, I am not a king player.
I was just joking.
I don't know how to play king.
I'm not a king main, I swear.
I don't know who king is.
Who is king?
Never seen that man in my life.
She's a robot?
Yeah, a robot would dress like that.
It seems like definitely a type of outfit where she can
never take off.
AI generated fashion!
I'll be able to send you out.
Wait.
My devil's power was in the battle.
In the future, he came to fight.
If the power is re-examined, then that will be the battle in
the battle.
It's Kazuyo-Chair's tournament.
The Z-Shin-Shin will start to come yeah he has to go he
needs the money he needs the inheritance wait apparently the
dad has 40 kids what happened to the 39 kids oh i think we
all know what happened to the 39 kids
Oh, grandpa has 40 kids.
Oh.
Wait, Lars is my brother?
39 kids left the chat.
You're looking at two of them in this scene and saw one in
the...
Wait, is this all just like...
Oh, Lars is the uncle.
Oh, my grandpa's the asshole.
I see.
Or the...
like is my dad my dad's the asshole and then he him and the
other is the Lars and the my dad is the is um my like their
brothers yeah okay oh okay I'm starting to figure this out
so both grandpa and dad are bad people and I think my game
crashed I can't tell yet I can't tell It's not moving.
Nothing's moving.
I can't tell.
Guys, I can't tell if it's baiting me.
Guys, did it crash?
I don't know.
Chicken has baited me so often.
I can't tell anymore.
I don't know.
Like, actually, I don't know.
let it cook okay let it cook the eight's not moving that's
why the eight's not moving
can't tell if terrible load times or if it's crashing i mean
to be fair we did like we did like survive for a while
though this is crashed okay to be fair i'll have to say
though far okay let's end this with a king fight i've
learned so much with playing jinn that i think we can end it
on let's let's do one last game and then we'll play king
today i couldn't tell if it was loading or crashing i just
decided to just force quit it
all right here we go yeah i couldn't tell if it was loading
or not it's so hard to tell for this game Tekken is like...
I just couldn't tell.
Wait, is the maintenance over?
Is it?
Fancy, welcome to the tomato farm.
Welcome, welcome.
Hey, the eight's moving, though.
Yay, Bandai.
All right, here you go.
Bye, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Grandpa threw dad off the cliff.
So dad threw grandpa in the volcano.
This is the whole story from Tekken.
What does...
Heaven.
That's all we need to know.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
All right.
King's death roll.
What's that?
Alexis, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
You gotta learn the Korean backdash and king's death roll.
Oh, shit.
I got all that, but I don't need that.
All right.
Let's see.
Uh.
Versus CPU.
Okay.
versus cpu all right yeah i'm ready to rep techinada evo
okay this is it wait okay this is it guys i learned so much
from king that i think i got this it's gonna be so easy
it's gonna be so easy i can feel it all I have to do is grab
alright hard you know what I think I'm ready for hard level
I'm ready for hard level I'll do random take me anywhere in
the world urban square let's go this is it I'll show you
guys I'll show you my power level right here by the way if
you're scoping out the competition if any like coaches or
like team like participants scoping out the competition i'm
not a kingming i'm just this is my very first time playing
him but i'll never main this character ever in my world i'll
never main him at all i'm just messing about
guys did i crash or is this loading we'll never know The 8's
not moving, guys.
Guys.
The 8's not moving.
I can't tell.
It crashed.
No!
It's forever.
Let's play a little game, guys.
The game crashed.
Guys, it's just because I love the main menu so much.
I swear I'll set up my new PC after before the tournament I
swear guys I'll definitely set up my new PC before the
tournament guys it'll be fine we'll be fine we'll be so
healthy
guys guys for any of my future competitors.
I'm going to be an Eddie main, so just learn how to counter
the Eddie spam.
That's all you need to know.
I will never play any other hero but Eddie.
I swear.
100% truth.
This would be the only time I ever play King today.
True.
So true.
Because I don't even say can get into the main menu any is
this a crash or is this loading for a very long time is this
i like this little game we play chat this this little fun
game that we play
yeah eddie my favorite apex legends i don't think this is
loading anymore It's part of the experience.
It's part of the experience, chat.
Guys.
Oh, it has to be loading.
My cursor's gone.
The 8 appeared.
Oh, no, my...
It's loading.
Look, the 8.
I swear the 8 was moving earlier.
See, it's moving.
Bandai.
Okay, there we go.
This is it.
This time.
This time I can fight.
Guys.
Where's the main...
menu oh there he is there's eddie eddie there you are i knew
you were gonna be here all right main menu time we made it
we made it to the menu we did it we actually made it to the
menu everybody no my pc is okay sh pc it's okay they don't
mean that i'll never replace you sh i swear pc the hyatt the
hyatt pc is just their decoration i swear i would never do
anything to you all right let's see practice versus cpu
i don't mean it
it's not lagging it's just your stream 4k eddie it's all low
quality it can't be 4k all right there you go all right my
very first time playing king my very first time never
touched this character in my life unlucky thank you the
super chat thank you thank you Anton thank you for the super
chat All right, hard.
This is it.
We got this.
Is that like PC he does?
They don't mean this.
I can't wait to just listen to the song.
This is like the soundtrack simulator.
Oh my god!
Nice.
Now we're at midnight.
Okay, how far did we get last time?
Here!
This is how far we got to, right?
I'm ready.
I'm ready for the next battle.
Guys, the particles stop.
The particles are moving.
Guys, the particles stop moving.
I don't feel the...
Why is the particles not moving?
Please.
Oh, it's moving!
We're so back!
There's me!
My 25 phrase!
It's okay.
Shh.
It's okay, PC.
I'll never leave you.
We don't need phrase for the grab.
Shh.
It's okay, PC.
Please stay strong, Friddy.
Please stay strong for me.
I don't know what's happening.
Stay strong PC.
Stay okay.
Here you go This is it boom and then they'll never expect
this boom
Hard that's fucking right First stop playing king by the
way.
I'll never play him again.
I swear
By the way, I swear I would not play him again for all the
people scoping out the competition.
There you go.
Oh, oh, don't worry.
I got this.
Boom.
And then I got this.
Yeah.
And I can grab you.
Easy.
Not a King Ming, by the way.
we're so back oh shit oh shit how are you gonna counter this
bam how the fuck did you counter this bam bam you don't you
don't counter this boom boom boom and then i swing you look
at me go and then
it easy this is hard CP go king go how does she do it don't
worry I'll never touch king again
sure that was hard that was hard yeah it was I know the
combo Go ultra hard Wait, how do I do ultra hard?
Do I just do a rematch?
If I click rematch, can I change the difficulty from
rematch?
Okay, that's not my main.
I don't know why you guys keep saying kings my main.
What the fuck?
Do I just do I just do like quick select?
Oh, quick select.
All right.
This is confirmed.
then all right and then wait how do i wait no i don't want
to be no i'm king i'm king okay there you go uh very hard
all right here you go get ready for the next battle i'm
ready i'm so ready this is it i'm so ready
okay let's see oh shit that is ultra hard oh my god that is
ultra hard
who would have thought that is ultra hard guys oh my god
he's countering stuff now that's right but you can't counter
this he countered it but it's okay he doesn't know about
this get grabbed oh you find that was a grab no no no oh
shit that's fucking right I didn't grab this tap oh shit
that's right but I blocked oh my god that's a lot of energy
oh he went double mode he went sickle mode but I also went
sickle mode that's fucking right
Nice.
Oh, shit.
Oh, my God.
He's countering me.
How does he know?
How does he know what I want to do?
I don't understand.
That's fine.
But I can do this, though.
And I can do...
Whoa, shit.
Oh, shit.
No.
Oh, God.
Come on.
Counter.
No, no, no.
No, no.
No.
Round four.
Fight.
Oh, God.
Nice.
Okay.
No!
How does he read my input?
How does he know?
I don't understand.
How does he know what I want to do?
That's crazy.
But it's too bad.
It's over.
It's so over.
I told you.
I knew it.
knew it no ai can download this brain no a no ai can read
what's going on in this brain go ultra hard oh let's do it
now go ultra all right that's right i don't care we go
harder ultra hard
I'm not King Main, by the way.
Just so you guys know, I'm just naturally gifted.
Hey, I can't read this.
Oh, shit.
That's fucking right.
You didn't expect me to go that way, right?
Oh, oh, shit.
Oh, shit.
But can you escape that grab?
No, you can't.
That's fucking right.
The grab!
Now swing him!
Escape this, nerd!
That's right, you don't expect this!
He expected it, guys.
But did he expect this, though?
I'm too powerful.
Oh, no.
Wait.
JK.
Yeah?
No.
Uh-uh.
CPU?
No, no, no, no, CPU!
No!
Oh no.
Easy.
How does she keep getting away with this?
The dokey grab.
Oh my god, the dokey grab is back!
It's back!
It never left!
The dokey grab never leaves.
Oh god.
It's actually input reading me now.
Holy shit.
He actually knows now.
How does he know?
Okay.
Oh my god, how the fuck?
How the fuck does he know this is my strength this entire
time?
Ultra hard goes hard.
Oh, nice.
It's fine.
No, it's not fine!
He's the counter grabbing me!
Holy shit!
He figured it out!
How did he figure... I don't understand.
How does he figure this out?
No, no, no, no, no.
I can do it too.
I can also do it...
This.
Oh my god.
Nice, that's fine.
That's fine.
It's okay.
We'll be fine.
It's not okay.
Oh my god.
He, no, please just, I need one grab.
I need one grab.
Yes!
Oh my god!
Yeah!
Undefeated!
Let's go!
It's not hard enough.
Let's fucking go!
I figured it out!
Don't kill the king.
Oh my god!
Oh my god, I can't believe I did this without my main
character!
Not a king main!
all right i think all right i think that's a good time to
call it for today toki the king the ultra hard master they
need a harder mode for me oh my god
ggs everybody oh what a way to call it here i can't believe
it we got all the way to ultra mode we fucking did it we
fucking did it guys oh anyway i'm gonna call it here
everyone we had two streams today so today is a good time to
rest now i've lot of work to do today so uh it's a great
time to stream techin for the first time techin 8 for the
first time and playing it for the first time a lot of fun i
had a lot of fun guys especially taking some sets off of uh
fucking quote unquote uh not pro sorry quote unquote the
good players of my dragoons you should be ashamed if i took
a set off you you should be ashamed
but all right guys so for the reason for those who are new
here the reason why i'm playing um it's because i got
invited to do sea jam slam too so obviously i'm a noob so
i'll be put in the noob category with everybody else so like
noobs will be fighting other noobs and that's why i'm
learning a character that a noob might have difficulty with
so which is not king it's eddie guys i'm talking about eddie
not king um Who's my trainer and coach?
I don't know.
I'm just waiting for it.
Apparently, this was the stream for them to figure out,
like, how they're going to balance it.
So, like, I hope that I look really bad.
So, I'm a new player.
I'm a new player.
I have no idea what I'm actually doing.
So, like, we had to do a stream.
We're, like, we had to do, like, at least an hour stream so
they can gauge our, like, skill level.
So, by the way, I'm a new player.
Please.
Treat me as a new player.
I'm so bad.
I can only go up.
I'm at rock bottom.
Anyway, guys, as always, everybody, stay hydrated, posture
check.
Get up and move around to get that blood flowing.
And if you stay up for me, head to bed.
Because you deserve it.
I'll see you guys next time, everybody.
Bye, guys.
Bye.